london-born asthma al-assad may have
seemed out of place in syria when she
first married one of the arab world
strongmen
i was born and raised in london i know
the central line extremely well whether
it was going to school going to
university
but over time the former investment
banker and wife of president bashar
al-assad
has cemented her position as one of the
most powerful people in the country
now sky news understands an
investigation in her birth town could
lead to charges
that she supported and encouraged
terrorism
[Applause]
bashar al-assad has denied war crimes
and says instead he has been fighting
terrorists
british lawyers say the syrian
government is guilty of a systematic
approach to the torture and murder of
civilians
including with the use of chemical
weapons
and that asma al-assad is among a number
of influential actors
that have encouraged and incited acts of
terrorism and
international crimes theoretically if
the metropolitan police agree with that
which has been submitted
and further evidence that they may
uncover during their own investigation
then they can seek to bring charges and
they can seek to extradite her to the uk
in a statement the metropolitan police
service told sky news
we can confirm that the mets war crimes
unit part of the counter-terrorism
command
received a referral on 31st of july 2020
relating to the ongoing syrian conflict
the referral is in the process of being
assessed by officers from the war crimes
unit
former friends of the couple say her
influence is growing
with reports she has political ambitions
to climb to the very top
you cannot compare the existing asthma
asthma assad to the previous virgin
which is emma al-acharas in london till
now when she succeeded to consolidate
a lot of power now she's number one in
in economy in syria
and the one that run all the development
about administration
and economy last year she was sanctioned
by the u.s government
despite this asma al-assad's influence
doesn't appear to be wavering
but how she uses that power is now under
scrutiny
sadia chowdhury sky news